So this is more differentiation of the
archetype fundamentally.
So you see the dragon of chaos here,
that potential manifesting itself into
this ambivalent feminine figure,
both both promise and threat.
And then I've.
I've mapped this one out.
So the ambivalent feminine figure,
so sort of multi valence gives rise to
the positive mother and then the
positive mother gives birth to the hero
and that's Hercules there and this.
I like this image a lot.
So Hercules is in this container so that
you can interpret that.
Both has something feminine,
that container but also as a
representative of culture because it's a
boat that is floating on the chaotic
ocean here.
So that target,
he asked to be in a container that
sustains him in the murky water of chaos
and you see he's going out into the
unknown and he's got a lion's skin on.
And that's partly because one of the
initiation rituals for,
for young men when the reliance say in
the Middle East and that wasn't very
long ago,
was that you had to go and kill a lion
with a spear and with a bow and Arrow or
something like that.
It's like that's impressive.
All things considered.
I mean you really think about that for a
minute.
You really want to go out and try to
kill a lion with a stick.
It's like it probably.
You probably wouldn't be quite the same
after you did that.
That would be my guess.
And so anyways,
so there's.
Hercules has got his lion skin on and
that shows that he's assimilated to the
lion,
the dominant sort of animal and that
he's also mastered it and he's got his
bow and Arrow to so he's.
He's going to hit the target properly.
He's not.
He's someone who doesn't seem because he
can hit the center of the target and
he's got this club which I really liked
because it's covered with eyes just like
Martech,
Mesopotamian hero.
Well,
what do you want to do when you go out
into the unknown,
it's like arm yourself and pay attention
and so that's what you're trying to
produce.
If you're a good mother is this figure
that can go out into the unknown,
armed,
accurate,
and able to pay attention and that's a
hell of a thing to participate in and
it's really fun.
I found having children incredibly
entertaining.
It's ridiculously entertaining thing to
do because for a bunch of reasons.
One is that it's the only relationship
you'll ever have in your life where you,
where you actually have a chance of
establishing something that's close to
perfect is with your kids because when
they're delivered to you,
so to speak,
they're there in some sense they're
perfect and your job is to maintain that
perfection.
If you can,
and you do that by being a good parent,
by being encouraging,
by being on their side,
by taking care of them,
and you can have an absolutely pristine
relationship with the child.
That doesn't mean it's not full of
trouble because it is,
but it's it.
It can easily be the best relationship
you'll ever have in your life.
In fact,
I think that's.
It can be the worst to and you know
sometimes you get unlucky in your child
is sick mentally or physically and
things fall apart and it's not your
fault,
but sometimes it is your fault,
but it's a real gift and you have to
play this game of protection and
encouragement,
right?
Protection and encouragement and get
that dynamic right,
and then you build,
you help someone develop into something
that's well exactly this,
that can take on the troubles of the
world forthrightly and man,
that's what you want.
That'll make it worthwhile,
that's for sure.